The hardest part about making the choice to get a divorce is like,
am I making the right choice?
Am I making the right choice?
But if you've been struggling with that decision for such a long time,
you should probably. You should get a divorce.
The first step in doing anything is thinking about it.
So the fact that you're thinking about it
and you can't stop thinking about it,
and your thoughts always go there,
and you never seem to fix the problem.
Things never seem to kinda get quite right.
It's. You're.
The reason you're holding on is because you know that divorce is hard,
so you're just trying to avoid the hard thing.
Because it would be so much easier,
so much fucking easier,
if he would just wake the fuck up and realize, like, hey,
I'm a person, too.
Hey, I'm a person, too.
And you're not fucking crazy for feeling like, hey,
I'm a fucking person, too.
My feelings matter, too.
They sure as fuck want you to feel crazy,
and they sure as fuck want you to think, well,
you're just not doing as much as the other women.
You're just not as good as the other women.
You're not as strong as the other women.
They're trying to continue that pick me game
that got us there in the first place,
but it doesn't work
after you're a little bit older and very much tired.
So if you have that nagging feeling,
Inside, you're not crazy.
You're not a bad woman. You're not a bad wife.
You're not a bad mother.
You're gonna make it. You'll be okay.
You'll find your fucking way.
Just like if that. When you're in a shitty marriage like that,
you're the one that's always figuring everything out. Anyway,
when the problems arise, you're the one that has to like,
oh, my god,
fine, I'll fucking do it myself. Anyway,
you're the one that fixes the shit and cooks the shit
and does the shit. And even no matter what the fucking problem is,
you're probably the one that does everything. Anyway,
it's not exactly what you thought it was gonna be.
So you're gonna be okay when you leave,
because you are that resourceful person.
You are capable of doing everything that you're already doing
and then doing it without that weight.
That's called the fucking glow up.